Now let's look at what we can
do with a camera like this.
So, again,
we know that if somebody gave me this
information I would have a camera.
And basically what I'm doing is,
to create this burn image,
remember our lectures on doing
things like convolution.
If I'm convolving with
a stock function like this,
blurring is basically equivalent to
convolution and this would be my output.
The size of this kind of suggests
the size of the step function that we,
you would have.
And of course what basically comes down,
and
there's a concept of a sinc function,
which basically says that.
And sinc function for
those of you curious,
basically is showing
the information about a signal.
And it basically says a sinc
function is a general form here and
basically is a sine wave that
decays with an amplitude 1 over x.
So as we move away,
it gets smaller and smaller.
This is one of the standard ways of
actually computing discrete Fourier
transforms and
it's one of the pairs that captures
the magnitude of a signal like this.
So this is, of course, one of the sinc
functions for a signal like this.